MEAN.
>> SAYS WHO?
WE CAN'T BE THE ONLY INTELLIGENT
LIFE.
>> SAYS WHO, ANTHONY?
>>> WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
THIS, THE U.S. IS ABOUT TO SHARE
MORE COVID VACCINES WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN
OFFERING TENS OF MILLIONS MORE
DOSES THAN INITIALLY PROMISED.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
ABOUT 70% OF AMERICANS ARE NOW
VACCINATED BUT MANY NATIONS ARE
STRUGGLING TO GET THE SHOTS.
THEY HAVE TURNED TO OTHER WORLD
POWERS LIKE CHINA TO FIND DOSES.
HOLLY WILLIAMS SAYS WHY THE U.S.
NEEDS TO DO MORE VACCINE
DIPLOMACY.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT BIDEN
ANNOUNCED THE U.S. WILL SHARE A
TOTAL OF 80 MILLION VACCINE
DOSES WITH THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
>> JUST LIKE IN WORLD WAR II
AMERICA WAS THE ARSENAL OF
DEMOCRACY IN THE BATTLE AGAINST
CO-VID PANDEMIC.
OUR NATION IS GOING TO BE THE
ARSENAL OF VACCINES FOR THE REST
OF THE WORLD.
>> Reporter: AND AMERICA HAS
PLENTY TO SHARE.
>> VACCINE SUPPLY IS OUTPAYS
DEMAND.
AROUND THE COUNTRY, SHOTS ARE
UNUSED.
>> Reporter: IT'S ORDERED ENOUGH
VACCINE TO VACCINATE THE
POPULATION TWICE OVER WHILE MANY
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE STILL
STRUGGLING TO SECURE THEM.
A UNITED NATIONS PROGRAM BACKED
BY THE U.S. HAS SO FAR DELIVERED
FEWER THAN 17 MILLION DOSES
WORLDWIDE, WHEN BILLIONS ARE
NEEDED.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
SAYS WE'RE AT RISK OF VACCINE
APARTHEID.
AND FOREIGN POLICY EXPERT IKE
FREYMANN SAID IT'S LEFT SOME OF
AMERICA'S ALLIES HELPLESS.
>> THEY CAN SEE IN THE HEADLINES
AMERICANS ARE GETTING BACK TO
NORMAL LIFE AND YET THEIR
GRANDMOTHER IS GETTING SICK
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET A
VACCINE.
>> IS IT DAMAGING FOR THE WEST?
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY DAMAGING THE
REPUTATION OF THE DEVELOPED
WORLD.
AND IT'S A FAILURE OF AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP.
>> Reporter: AND DR. RADAVID AG
TOLD US IF OTHER COUNTRIES DON'T
VACCINATE, THEY COULD CREATE
MORE COVID VARIANTS THAT ARE A
DANGER TO US ALL.
>> IT'S A MORAL IMPERATIVE.
IT'S A SCIENTIFIC IMPERATIVE
THAT WE VACCINATE THE GLOBE, NOT
ONLY TO HELP OTHER PEOPLE, BUT
TO PROTECT US.
♪
>> Reporter: BUT MANY NATIONS
ARE NOW TURNING TO AMERICA'S
RIVAL, GIVING THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WIN HEARTS AND
MINDS.
WHILE AMERICA'S PROMISED 80
MILLION DOSES, ACCORDING TO
MONITORING GROUPS CHINA AND
RUSSIA HAVE DONE DEALS TO
DELIVER AROUND 600 MILLION
VACCINE DOSES, EACH GLOBALLY.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT JUST
HOW EFFECTIVE THEIR VACCINES
REALLY ARE.
>> WHAT WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT IS
THAT THEY'RE NOT UP TO PAR WITH
THE WESTERN VACCINE.
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET,
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, GRANDMA THINKS
SHE'S PROTECTED, SHE HUGS HER
GRANDSON CAN SPREAD THE VIRUS.
AND IF THE VIRUS BEGINS TO
SPREAD IT CAN CREATE NEW
VARIANTS THAT ARE RESISTANT TO
ALL OF THE VACCINES AND SPREAD
TO OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
ANNOUNCEMENT, FREYMANN TOLD US
IS A SMALL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
>> IT'S GOING TO HAVE HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOSES TO START
EXPORTING.
>> YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE U.S.
CAN STILL TURN THIS AROUND?
>> I THINK IT CAN.
>> Reporter: FOR "CBS THIS
MORNING," HOLLY WILLIAMS,
LONDON.
>> THAT'S WHY THEY CALL IT A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
>> YEAH.
>> I THINK SOMETIMES IN AMERICA,
WE'RE SO USED TO THINKING ABOUT
OURSELVES AND PAGE ATTENTION TO
WHAT HAPPENS HERE, BUT WE REALLY
DO HAVE TO PAY ATTENTION TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING AROUND THE
WORLD.
>> WELL, IF THE WORLD DOESN'T
GET VACCINATED, WE KEEP THE
VIRUS ALIVE.
AS DR. AGUS POINTED OUT IT CAN
MUTATE AND ADJUST AND COME BACK
AT US WHICH IS WHY IT'S SO
IMPERATIVE THAT WE GET VACCINES.
AND THE BEST VACCINES.
>> EXACTLY, AND YOU HAVE TO
TRACK THE VARIANT AND WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN EACH AND EVERY
COUNTRY.
>> YEAH.
>> I REMEMBER HOW COMFORTABLE I
FELT IN THIS CHAIR, WELL, IT'S
IN CHINA, I HAVEN'T BEEN TO
CHINA.
I HAV